пориві який з тревела снаки в нору
хамам біля майна
за допомогою квадрокоптера активіста
автомайдану створ джучі відкриття рік
тому для граматику прай з трьома назарами
девід повідають особистості мовляв чиновники
втирай з трьом і як свої декларації про
доходи по передніх руки вниз тлін і все
свій залишки від часто густо за галина до
віч правову на дубу новому столітті можна і
не повідомляти і я куди dance київських
судив до якову навідалася активісти
побачили це ще буду і над пам'ятаєш туди
bunawan і алое в реєстр війна вниз
сфотати юний вигляд декларацію етапу
ту мету по суті поховати рештки
поховання майна
zarik після відкриття реєстрів активісти
зафіксувалася силах були кермо краще не
виродки нах по садів tea party моху або
прописування майна народу ніж
домагалася і запутати і сліди та успішно
курей залишалося від них що державі забраку
ресурсів обидва реєстр і став і технічно так
з куналом жерлом інформації та велика
проблема на накази та реєстром у с
реєстром вас portals транспортним за
особливо вин на повний хід ми розуміємо
ще можна вказати а можна покарати
автомобіль не пам'ятаю реєстр та за грози
отримані перевірки тепер уже
електронних декларацій деяких чиновників
чоловік вони будуть куди ти докінза жовтня
національне агентство , залякування
корупції
що правда в румунських we still якщо розум
поза рахунок вона явно стіна т.к. на лижному
програмного забезпечення та як могло ви
кунут і головне завдання
так larva не пори мене ти про будку то
ви витрати по садів tell me кашель у нас
ну скажімо а так там за рексара було 3
тисяч доларів а куполи натра мільйони
нору homo статусів ж розпив падіння
алана жанр мови вигляд трохи його
модулів сказала ворушим на потребу
цю тему станції самий якраз
розробок у романтиці та активісти
зібрали багатство інформації просто to keep
us a doubt шлях або украй
я хочу музика не помітити на правди та
дані обидва не розпізнає пізно до
незаконному в багажний відсік чиновники
активісти самі відправляти свої докази
набу
аджі антикорупція детективи можете
відкривати і кримінальне право Дженні
проти по саду Стів не
сережки зі свердлінням мови